te régis on paie les analystes
géopolitiques et directeur exécutif
d'interpol conseil
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors patrice talon image
de modernisateur d'hommes d'affaires
ambitieux c'est ce sur quoi ils avaient
misé pour se faire élire en 2016 on va
tout d'abord parler du bilan économique
cinq ans plus tard quel bilan dresses
répond justement le bilan économique de
façon je dirais je prends si les aspects
macroéconomiques effet témoin c'est un
bilan qui est plutôt positif avec une
stabilité justement fiscale avec une
stabilité au niveau des impôts je pense
qu'il fait doigt le bilan économique il
est laid il est plutôt a salué dans la
mesure où c'est un pigiste moi qui a
affronté de crise à la fois la crise du
combiné la crise la fermeture des
frontières avec le nigeria mais qui
justement arrive à dégager une forte
croissance avec un pib qui est projetée
par exemple en 2021 à 6,6 pensante sait
qui est quand même inédit et historique
à salluit mais cette villa économique
pour tout vous dire en réalité c'est un
bilan qui qui ne satisfait que les
classes moyennes les 90 supérieur et les
centres urbains
larry hâlés en réalité c'est que la
croissance économique n'est pas une
cuisine n'est pas partagée dans ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui le faut moi j'aime
beaucoup croisé justement à la fois le
taux de progrès et la croissance
économique aujourd'hui le taux de
pauvreté même dans les centres dans les
centres que ce soit dans les centres
urbains et périurbains et dans les
musiques urbaines est très très élevé
pratiquement à 50% dans ce qui était
évidemment au delà du bilan économique
qui peut être flatteur si le plan
international si le plan macroéconomique
la réalité que justement le béninois
moyens le dinah lamda aujourd'hui ne
voit pas exactement les fruits et ne
veut pas que cette croissance économique
a lors des manifestations récentes qui
se sont soldées par un mort parce que
les adversaires les protestataires
dénoncent l'absence de figures majeures
de l'opposition
où sont-ils justement ses opposants et
ses opposantes la plupart des opposants
sont les parfaits mais je dire les
opposants notables sont en exil en
france aux états unis et automatique du
goût qui a été accusé de financement du
terrorisme qui aujourd'hui est en prison
doit ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui le
véritable la véritable opposition
politique en fait elles et les ordures
et les ordres ou et les deux les deux
autres dont vous avez évidemment parler
sont des duels justement qui
desserviront selon les observateurs car
valider la légitimité qu'à légitimer les
élections du président à londres ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui au bénin on est
quand même en droit de se poser la
question du plach et du pluralisme
d'opinion du pluralisme politique
mais moi je me méfie quand même assez
des qualifications extrême jeu quand je
lis la presse le béné souvent taxé le
bénin actuel est souvent taxé de détails
date au real je pense qu'il faut faire
attention
le crif des pressions de sa démocratie
le bio n'est pas encore la bio elle
n'est pas encore la birmanie mais il
faut être très très vigilant si les
tensions politiques parce que vous avez
rappelé qu'il y avait eu un mort je
viens d'apprendre qu'il y avait un
deuxième mort donc je pense que j'étais
moins 102 morts de trop dans un conteste
dans un gigantesque a manqué à ses
fichiers
et rien ne dit que difficilement je suis
resté des manifestations encore plus
grave justement ce qu'on a un spectre
d'une crise post-électorale totalement
comme en guinée comme en côte d'ivoire
tout est possible aujourd'hui je crois
que le terreau est bien faire c'est
justement pour qui une explosion et donc
il appartient justement à la classe
politique afin de l'opposition qu'elle
soit que c'est l'opposition kg ce mois
ci le terrain que ça le pouvoir
aujourd'hui nos revenus quand même
considérable je pense qu'aujourd'hui le
présent talons il passera dimanche
prochain c'est tellement avec un sort la
réalité c'est que l'après-élection me
pose la période post élection gérer de
façon qui est pas de tension et qui
malheureusement qu'il ait pas de mort
comme on a pu déjà le constater en début
en début de campagne électorale alors le
bénin était
quand même un modèle de démocratie dans
la région à ce que patrice talon a un
peu changé la donne le bénin pendant
longtemps il fait des morts était
considéré comme l'un des rares pyj
seulement à avoir amorcé sa transition
démocratique dont c'était quelque chose
et des acquis démocratiques ce week end
nabil et noah s'est inventé beaucoup à
l'étranger aujourd'hui il faut dire
clairement les choses il présente à
l'autre mais davantage plus l'accent sur
les colonies plus l'accent sur la
croissance économique que la
valorisation et la promotion des
libertés publiques et la démocratie dans
ce qui fait que ont tous remarqué fait
des mois qu'ils rétrécissement de l'état
de droit il ya heureusement des libertés
publiques mais finalement c'est un choix
qui est totalement assumée et peut-être
qu'ils s'étaient que le second mandat se
réinvente agissements qui reviendra
peut-être à adidas fait davantage plus
démocratique toujours est il
qu'aujourd'hui il ya quand même
questionnement sur sur la relation entre
l'état de droit en tête démographie et
la croissance économique est-ce qu'il
faut valoriser la croissance économique
au détriment la démocratie ou est ce qui
n'est peut-être pas inutile de dire les
deux à la fois
régis on paie merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
analyste géopolitique et directeur
exécutif d'un tacle conseil merci